welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and the boys has been a
bloody diabolical horror show which we
have loved breaking down weekly in our
boys underground after show to share our
disgust
and in some cases guilty pleasure
the season 2 finale is days away and its
episode trailer hints at
just enough of how this final hour will
wrap up the big mysteries we have had
this season i'm gonna break down this
footage and puzzle together other
remaining trailer footage to answer
who was behind the recent mind-blowing
twist ending and
the major characters whose bloody
insides we might see next episode
spoiler warning before we continue and
here we go
we can't just kill everyone that's
exactly what we're gonna do
we're even now holy why are you doing
this because i went back in
so i need her gone
they took ryan don't you worry i won't
find your
we are your heroes we are here to serve
and protect
you the bromo picks up right where last
episode ended when the boys saw heads
explode at congresswoman newman's
congressional hearing on vaught
the victims included a trained speedster
replacement shockwave former bot cso
jonah vogelbaum about to testify
a congressman newman's aide lisa and at
least
10 others based on on-screen pops in
audible pops that we could hear over the
screams
so quick rundown of the suspects many
believe cindy the escaped soup
experiment from sage grove could be
behind this
given her similar bod bursting powers
however
her telekinesis appears to be more
implosion-based and encompassing the
whole body instead of just the head
exploding cleanly off its neck there are
also questions about her opportunity and
her motive like she was locked up in
sage grove during the similar killing of
rainer and she likely would not
willingly cooperate with stormfront or
vot like if she had been drugged and
forced to do this
like she seems like a bit too convenient
of the answer to the question conspiracy
theorists someone you might say
lee harvey oswald escapatsy another
suspect people believe
could be the head of the scientology
inspired church of the collective
alistair adana since shockwave was among
the kills
and alistair had made promises to eight
train to get him back into the seventh
but with a train still anti-vaught based
on this promo
we're even now holy why are you doing
this because i went back in so i need
her
gone i doubt that vacancy worked out
that way now it could also be the extra
i'd be calling
beardy who seems to be looking in the
general direction of the head pops as of
doing it with his
mind and he does have that menacing
golden state killer among the blurry
background faces vibe but really let's
be honest the most logical culprit is
vot head stan edgar who yeah would be
the most eager to silence vogelbaum
and use a false flag suit terrorist
attack one that he could blame on cindy
as grounds to stage a coup for
homelander and stormfront and take over
the us government and the white house
the shot of the first american president
george washington getting sprayed with
blood
could have been a hint toward that plot
against the current white house of the
show
and the opening scene of the season
showed edgar negotiating with the
secretary of defense
over how exactly the seven will fit into
the chain of command
and if a last minute appointment of
homelander to the position of secretary
of defense would technically make
homelanders sixth in the line of
succession
according to the 25th amendment then
again homelander is beep would make him
first in line
i mean let's be honest homelander isn't
very patient he seems like the kind of
[ __ ] who drives up on the shoulder to
merge five cars ahead
instead of doing it just now waiting
your turn a white house takeover seems
to be the coup
that raynor was referring to seconds
before her death
it's a coup from the inside
ma'am your nose and in this promo
homelander's creepy final speech looks
very much like a grim
composed speech given right before or
maybe right after taking
the oath of office we are your heroes
we are here to serve and protect you and
he says hero again there which
you know i just bring up because every
time homelander says the word hero it
seems like it's either right before
or right after someone dies horribly you
are the real heroes
and you my friend are a true hero
so if anyone in red white and blue ever
calls you a hero even if they're
carrying a captain america's shield it's
probably a good idea to run
yeah i know i get excited anytime i see
the red white and blue but another star
that has me seeing red white and blue
that gets me excited
is the star blast flavor of bang energy
thanks to bang for sponsoring this video
mark every can of bang is 16 ounces it
contains 300 milligrams of caffeine
and it is sugar-free and has zero
calories yet
it tastes great with over 20 different
flavors to choose from one of those
great flavors is
our friend star blast
[Music]
check out bang on instagram you can get
off your order at bangenergy.com when
you use the code newrockstars25
there you can buy cans of bang energy
including their sweet tea and keto
coffee flavors
you can also get clothing fitness
supplements all kinds of stuff to be
your best
bang self thanks again to bang energy
for sponsoring this video get 25
off at bang energy.com using the code
newrockstars25 okay so after the
exploding heads attack episode seven
ended with butcher thinking about his
next move
what the [ __ ] do we do now and we
speculated that could be the boys
finally taking compound v themselves to
fight the seven head-to-head
but now judging from camiko's rocket
launcher the battle plan appears to just
be
we can't just kill everyone that's
exactly what we're gonna do so the
mission here appears to be all around
ryan
homelander and stormfront took away
becca's son ryan actually another shot
in this trailer shows homelander
launching again with this kid in tow we
do see shots of becca running in the
woods through a drainpipe apparently
escaping the compound and arriving
to the pawn shop they took him damn ryan
so rescuing ryan for becca appears to be
butcher's call to action
don't you worry i won't find yourself
but uh i don't know how eager butcher is
gonna be to save ryan per se
but hey a valiant effort could win becca
back despite ryan getting fried halfway
through a blindside reenactment
really the balance of power has shifted
starlight and queen maeve appear to be
working alongside the boys with atran
continuing to help them with intel
and i'm assuming that finally gives them
details vots white house coup plan
maybe just evidence that links stan
edgar to the exploding heads whatever
evidence rainer had right before she
died and we got confirmation that the
finale episode will feature a battle
between them
and stormfront she blows up this
airplane hangar in a clearing maybe it's
a rendezvous point for the boys we also
see homelander touch down to this
similar rural location maybe he gets
there after the fight is over but there
is a clip another footage showing maeve
a fighting storm front in this location
along with another shot of maeve kamiko
and starlight stomping
presumably storm front because another
shot she zaps kamiko off her
really one of the biggest lingering
mysteries is this shot of homelander
from all the way back last december
opening the very first teaser for the
second season
this particular shot has yet to appear
in the seven episodes of season two thus
far
so it must appear in the upcoming finale
episode and i am assuming it is going to
be a
key moment from the finale whose blood
is on homelander here who is he looking
down at some are suggesting this could
take place right after the head pops in
the congressional hearing which
did spray homeland with a bit of blood
perhaps he's laying to rest the body of
jonah vogelbaum the closest thing to a
father figure he's ever had but
homelander didn't get
that much blood on his face during the
massacre i guess the c-span feed did cut
off in the middle of it there could have
been another pop that got home later
squarely in the face but based on
homelanders expression here he's looking
down in what is that sadness
love grief whatever you call homelanders
emotion that is not rage or apathy and
we looked over and saw vocal moms head
pop feet away from him homelander didn't
look that horrified so one theory is
becca who
i'm not sure will survive this season
though i don't know how much homelander
really cares about or at least i don't
know if he cares about her that face
much my gut tells me this is either ryan
or stormfront
it's important to note the blood on
homelanders face doesn't necessarily
belong to the person or thing he's
looking down at
he does float down the camera face is
already covered in blood almost as if to
say homelander left one skirmish soaked
in the blood from that
to then find the body of an unintended
victim of his destruction or
maybe it's a true bloodbath stormfront
kills becca and then ryan
in that rage snaps and kills stormfront
which could have been set up by
homelander lasering her
you know chest with ryan's heat vision
being even more powerful
and then maybe homelander covered in
stormfront's blood from ryan killing her
then snaps himself and kills ryan his
son or you know maybe homelander while
flying with ryan hugged him too hard
and he crushed them all over himself or
maybe ryan finally learns how to fly on
his own and homelander accidentally
flies through him
all kinds of horrifying directions this
could go i want you to comment down
below with your theory for who
homelander is looking at in this shot
and if you really want to get into the
boys join me as we discuss theories
about the show onto rockstar's official
discord server all you got to do is
become a patron at patreon.comrockstars
subscribe to new rockstars hit that
notification bell
follow me on instagram at eavos follow
new rockstars subscribe to the boys
underground podcast feed wherever you
get your podcast thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you